[Musique]
mais
huguette bouchardeau bonjour la campagne
maintenant officiel est bien engagée et
vous êtes amené à présenter chaque jour
aux propositions sur des thèmes divers
vous en avez choisi trois aujourd'hui
qui sont l'agriculture le tiers monde et
le désarmement alors je voudrais vous
poser une première question pourquoi ces
trois thèmes ensemble quel est le bien
que vous faites entre ces trois sujets
au le lien entre ces trois sujets
agriculture désarmement tiers-monde
il est très simple c'est le lien entre
les problèmes de la survie et les
problèmes de la mort
aujourd'hui l'agriculture qui produit
notre nourriture
c'est ce qui peut vraiment nous aider à
survivre et de la manière dont se fera
la gestion de l'agriculture dépendra
aussi le bien-être le mieux être de
l'avenir seulement en même temps que des
gens travaillent pour nous nourrir
il y en a d'autres qui accumule des
forces de mort et pendant que dans cette
année 79 l'année de l'enfance mourey 12
millions d'enfants dans le monde
pendant ce temps là est bien en
accumuler de quoi tuer cinq fois de
suite
l'humanité entière par l'armement
nucléaire
alors vous voyez le lien il existe
vraiment alors des gens qui travaillent
pour nourrir les autres vous en aval des
deux avec vous je ris je vous demandais
de me représenter
alors il s'agit de bernard lambert qui
est syndicaliste paysan bien connu je
crois et puis marie joue mater qui est
agricultrice sur le plateau du larzac
on va commencer avec monsieur lambert
lors bernard lambert vous êtes vous êtes
un paysan un vrais paysans de ta paysans
qui travaillent la terre n'êtes pas
seulement un syndicaliste qui contrôle
dans les bureaux parisiens vous êtes
vraiment un agriculteur installé dans
l'ouest alors parlez nous un peu de la
condition de des agriculteurs en france
aujourd'hui en 81 oui tout d'abord une
précision
je ne suis pas adhérent au psu et le
syndicat auquel j'appartiens n'est pas
la courroie de transmission d'un parti
politique
les polonais nous on pouvait d'ailleurs
qu'il ne fallait pas s'engager dans
cette voie
mais ceci étant dit l'ouverture et la
prise de parole qui est permise au jour
d'aujourd'hui je l'apprécierai très
forte mais je suppose que si vous êtes
la saison 2 est quand même assez proche
des positions du ps us au moins sur le
guen agricole je voudrais bien que les
partis de gauche fassent le même
ouverture alors parlez nous un peu de la
situation par exemple d'un jeune paysan
aujourd'hui qui doit commencer à
s'installer il doit démarrer dans cette
profession
il faut bien voir que le jeune qui
s'installe est obligé de filins certains
itinéraires ci n'est pas venu au monde
tout habillé riches
il doit pour commencer empruntés ne peut
pas s'installer autrement il va voir la
banque le crédit agricole qu'on appelle
à tort mutuelle qui n'est qu'une banque
c'est la première du monde d'ailleurs et
la banque lui impose directement une
surface minimum à type de production et
des contrats avec une firme qu'il
s'agisse de coopérative d'ailleurs ou de
firmes privées ne change rien ils
entrent forcément dans la mécanique dans
une mécanique qui fait qu'il sera même
dépossédé de la direction de son travail
il lui faudra produire comme lui
indiquera la firme et il aura le revenu
qu'on voudra bien lui laisser plaisir
que l'image du paysan maître sur ses
terres mettre dans son champ célia image
t rim est seul maître à bord après dieu
c'était sûrement livré pour le mener
pour les paysans ni pour les marins je
pense que c'est totalement fini on est
entre les mains du monde de l'argent est
là parce que l'impression d'une
profession étrangler par le crédit par
les firmes agroalimentaires par
absolument et je crains tout quitte
exemple qu'on pourrait développer plus
lorsque les paysans ont été condamnés à
pour gagner tout simplement leur vie est
péniblement ça n'empêchait pas un
certain nombre de faire faillite de
mettre des hormones dans les veaux ce
qui donnait une marchandise douteuses à
tous points de vue il dangereux un
exemple dans tout le monde se souvient
et c'est nous mêmes nous l'avons des
noms des noms c'est important plate
lorsqu'ils ont été amenés à faire star
ce n'est pas qu'ils voulaient polluer
mais c'est parce que il n'avait pas de
revenus ils avaient des pertes
quand il ne faisait pas ce qu'on leur a
ordonné de faire les gars de bouchardeau
je suppose que vous faites à peu près la
même analyse du phénomène paysans
actuellement mais vous appartient en
tant que candidat de dire si vous avez
des propositions à faire donc ça change
bien sûr écoutez j'ai jaugé coûte de
temps en temps j'entends avec assez de
stupéfaction ce que j'entends dire sur
le monde agricole
j'entends dire que on continuerait de
voter plus à droite qu'à gauche
dans le monde agricole disait satisfait
et pourtant je voudrais simplement
parler là aux gens qui vivent dans les
conditions que vient de décrire bernard
lambert c'est vrai que ça me paraît
impossible qu'on continue d'accepter les
conditions qui sont faites et que le
minimum c'est qu'il y ait un revenu sur
décent pour tous ceux qui vivent du
travail de la terre
quand je dis ce j'entends aussi celle
parce que aujourd'hui les femmes
partagent le travail des hommes dans
l'agriculture mais la plupart du temps
les femmes agricultrices n'ont pas de
statut
elles ne sont que conjointe d'un
exploitant agricole
mais en même temps je voudrais dire que
l'essentiel
bernard lambert vient de le souligner
c'est que l'agriculteur puisse d'abord
avoir eu la maîtrise de son outil de
travail la terre quand je dis ça je veux
pas dire que l'agriculteur sera
forcément propriétaires de la terre
plusieurs dépisteurs ne donnant pas cela
je le paye seulement c'est ça alors il
ya justement là parmi vos invités une
jeune femme qui fait partie de ces gens
dont on essaye de leur retirer leur
outil de travail vous êtes une
les âmes du larzac et le larzac tout le
monde sauf à valmont bernard langlois
excusez moi mais vous avez vous ne
m'avez interrompu là mais je voudrais
quand même ajouter autre chose parce que
je viens de parler des agriculteurs il
faut parler des produits qu'ils font
vous savez que beaucoup d'agriculteurs
ont honte aujourd'hui de ce qu'ils sont
obligés de produire et que vraiment
produire des animaux bourrés d'hormones
ou vous ré d'antibiotiques des légumes
bourrés de nitrates et bien ce n'est pas
les agricultures les agriculteurs qui
désirent le faire au contraire et je
pense que il leur faudrait pouvoir
travailler moins haut rendement pour
pouvoir produire une nourriture de
qualité à laquelle nous consommateurs
nous sommes intéressés jusqu'à l'heure
personne ne s'en plaindrait
effectivement marie-jo matin vous êtes
donc agricultrice au larzac alors le
larzac on en a beaucoup entendu parler
au cours des dernières années c'est un
plateau dans le sud de la france
un cos escos vous et discuté par l'armée
française qui veut étendre son champ de
manoeuvre et puis dix ans mais alors on
en a beaucoup parlé dans les années 70
on en parle un peu moins maintenant
quelle est la situation actuellement sur
le larzac et bien la situation actuelle
c'est qu'on est tous expropriés
l'armée est propriétaire une somme tous
arts et culture encore nous restons nous
ne céderons aucun hectares la douche
c'est combien de personnes que 103
personnes toujours sont toujours sans
trois en un réducteur y en a qui sont
partis il y en a d'autres qui sont
revenues on a remis en état des terres
on les arts cultiver on a retapé de
vieille bergerie les bergeries soit à
nouveau occupée par départ des brebis et
villages ont à nouveau occupé les on a
aussi construit une bergerie
personnellement nous on nous avons
construit une bergerie et nous sommes
pas prêts à le laisser à l'armée pour
faire un des hangars engins militaires
si je comprends bien on est dans une
situation juridique assez curieuse sur
le papier il ya plus de paysans du
larzac qu'ils ont été rayées sont
expropriés et en fait vous êtes toujours
là et vous continuez à vous frotter aux
militaires tous les jours quand ça se
passe sur le terrain
mais sur le terrain dernièrement il ya
des militaires il s'approchait un peu
trop près de mordant qui est un village
qui leur appartient c'est vrai où ils
sont propriétaires de toutes les terres
mais nous sommes tous venus les paysans
et nous avons raccompagné les
les chars militaires dans leur kangoo
c'est à dire qu' il y avait dix chats
ils sont repartis et sont retournés dans
leurs camps militaires et les jeeps du
colonel aussi qui d'ailleurs est rentré
dans une voiture des paysans et s'est
sauvée alors on a demandé aux aux
gendarmes qui étaient là de faire un
constat d'élite fitch sais pas si ça
marchera bernard lambert vous n'avez pas
de problème ou avec l'armée dans l'ouest
non mais vous êtes solidaires delà des
paysans du larzac qu'on pense que la
terre a un but précis c'est celle de
nourrir les hommes et on pense que
l'accaparement par l'armée avec des
usages leur triste qu'elle en fera soit
pour les ennemis de l'extérieur soit
pour l'ennemi de l'intérieur ne nous
convient pas du tout vous avez
l'impression que ma ajoutant que l'armée
dépense beaucoup au larzac
tous les jours on les voit les chars
militaires s'amuse à défaire des murs
est sur le plateau il fonce dedans toute
cette énergie qui est dépensé les
hélicoptères nous survolent sans arrêt
tous les matins souvent toute la matinée
ya des tirs tout ça c'est l'argent qui
part en fumée
quand on nous parle qui a pas d'argent
pour faire des crèches des équipements
collectifs pour l'éducation nationale
qui a pas d'argent pour les gens qui
sont pas titulaires moi j'ai pas parce
que on en vient à la bouche ardo
deuxième thème de cet entretien
c'est celui de la défense nationale le
gaspillage de l'armée tels que le
dénonce marie jo est ce que c'est
vraiment un gaspillage et bien vous vous
souvenez monsieur bernard langlois de
l'émission qu'avait faite le président
valéry giscard d'estaing pour nous
présenter la force de frappe française
il nous avait montré que du bout de son
index
il pouvait appuyer sur le bouton
fatidique et qu'à ce moment là les
mirages partirait dans une direction
les fusées du plateau d'albion partirait
dans une autre que les missiles placés
sur les sous marins atomiques allait
partir dans tous les sens et que en dix
minutes on allait atteindre des villes
au delà des frontières de l'union
soviétique et moi je me suis dit
vraiment où en sont ils les français
pour accepter
une démonstration de ce genre parce que
si en dix minutes
le président de la république peut ainsi
décidé d'envoyer une force de mort
capable d'aller tuer ce sont les
chiffres
deux millions de personnes et biens dans
le même temps alors vraiment tu crois
qu'en dix minutes que les celles qui
suivront la france risque d'être
transformés que ça c'est une glace y
nucléaire c'est tout le pari de la
dissuasion c'est le pari de qui a été
fait par l'armée française et par l'état
français
oui il y en eut pourront causer des
morts qui sont dissuasives aux autres
pays pour nous attaquer alors vous êtes
content mais dissuasive mais dissuasif
de quoi parce que vraiment pour
dissuader il faut avoir la force
suffisante mais notre force de frappe
française est très inférieur aux forces
de feu qui existent aujourd'hui aux
états unis et en union soviétique
moi je me dis même de temps en temps que
s'il ya tellement de candidats à
l'elysée c'est peut-être bien que c'est
le seul endroit en france il ya un abri
antiatomique par dessous alors voyez
noms dont vous êtes pour le désarmement
nucléaire
et vous seriez d'accord pour que la
france unilatéralement commence à
désarmer oui c'est cela
moi je pense à penser comme ça
pratiquement peut-être nous sommes
peut-être les seuls à penser cela dans
la gauche ne serait pas la première fois
que le père issue serait le seul à un
moment à penser juste et que les autres
suivraient ensuite écouté aujourd'hui je
crois d'ailleurs que ce n'est pas du
tout une position utopiste irréaliste au
contraire il y en europe suffisamment de
force pour faire une alliance
différentes une alliance internationale
pour le désarmement nucléaire en europe
le parti travailliste onglet la gauche
du parti socialiste allemand des forces
en suède en norvège en août riches sont
aujourd'hui favorables à ce désarmement
nucléaire en europe allant tout le
problème du désarmement c'est de savoir
par où on va commencer
nous nous disons un pouvoir de gauche en
france devraient chercher à commencer ce
désarmement est d'ailleurs il y aurait
là une possibilité d'accord pas
seulement en europe
il y aurait une possibilité des records
dans les pays autour du bassin
méditerranéen
et avec des pays du tiers-monde qui
aujourd'hui vous le savez pas ce 14,3
pour cent de leur produit national brut
à des dépenses d'armement on va venir
envahir d'autres sites entièrement
d'huguette bouchardeau mais je voudrais
quand même que vous nous préciser un
petit peu quel type de défense nationale
vous envisagez pour la france si vous
lui retirer l'armé nucléaire si vous
supprimez les crédits à l'armée de
métier qu'est ce qu'on fait est-ce qu'on
m'attend tenu que faire d'éventuels
agresseurs envahissent le territoire
eh bien non mais simplement évoquant
l'exemple de la yougoslavie
c'est un petit pays et en 48 49 ce pays
a su avec une défense populaires sans la
hiérarchie de nos armées résister à la
menace de forces qui l'enserrait et puis
aujourd'hui et je trouve encore ce la
meilleure
il y as en pologne des gens qui aux
mains nues
simplement par la grève par la
mobilisation populaire sont capables de
dire non à des chars qui sont déjà sur
leur territoire vous voyez je crois que
défense populaires ça veut dire quelque
chose et que ce serait vraiment une
alternative à cette accumulation de mort
qui nous coûtent si cher et qui coûte
cher aux tirs mans nous en revenons
maintenant au troisième volet puisque
effectivement une bonne part des budgets
de l'état des pays en voie de
développement passe à acheter des armes
achetées des mirages acheter des bombes
alors là je crois que vous avez aussi
beaucoup de choses à dire bien sûr le
tiers-monde
nous avons des contrats avec lui des
contrats des changes
mais ces contrats des changes ce sont
des contrats qui appauvrissent le
tiers-monde au lieu de l'enrichir pour
aller vite
un exemple le sénégal nous avons
supprimé dans les pays d'afrique des
cultures qui servait à la nourriture de
tous les jours à la subsistance et
pourquoi pour leur demander d'exporter
chez nous des haricots verts en plein
hiver ou pour leur demander de faire de
l'arachide parce que l'arachide c'est
notre bifteck pommes frites l'arachide
ça sert à nourrir nos bovins
ça sert à faire notre cuisine est par
contre là bas on en est à ne plus avoir
de quoi se nourrir
quant à lambert on peut imaginer un
autre type de relations entre les
agriculteurs les pays développés comme
la france et l'agriculture du
tiers-monde je te crois mais je crois
surtout qu'en exploitant très fortement
les uns ont fait disparaître les hôtes
économiquement et ce n'est pas n'importe
qui c'est tous les jours des firmes
comme viande ce que pas par exemple
n'hésite pas à importé d'argentine de la
viande qui ne coûte rien et ça ruine les
paysans d'ici parce que là bas les
peones des ouvriers agricoles on les
paie coup de fusil fusil français bien
sûr c'est vrai encore pour des problèmes
comme le lait yoplait nestlé commence à
y implanter des productions extérieures
sur la base de rabatteurs qui ne coûte
rien comme pour le textile on transfère
les productions les légumes même en
pleine saison
c'est en train de ce qui est c'est ce
qui est en train de se passer où je
réagis très fort en tant que paysan
c'est que je sais que satura d'autres
paysans 7 madoff payait francs de
l'heure elle n'a plus la production
puisque c'est elle s'occupe r d
production d'exportation la production
qui servait à sa nourriture et la faim
augmente mais resservi quotidienne et
c'est ça la politique du capitalisme et
d'argent pour la demander bouchard de
conclure cette émission parce que
l'heure tourne
huguette alors résumons nous vous avez
choisi ces trois thèmes
vous pensez que c'est important qu'on
pose ces problèmes là sur la place
publique pourquoi après tout on pourrait
se dire que le tiers monde ça nous
concerne pas tellement ou que la
défensive bien sûr je sais bien le
tiers-monde
ça ne nous concerne pas tellement on en
est à une élection présidentielle on ne
va pas regarder trop
au delà de nos frontières et puis à quoi
bon parler des travailleurs immigrés par
exemple que le tiers-monde est obligé
d'envoyer travailler chez nous puisque
eux ils ne votent pas et bien moi je
pense je pense non seulement à notre
génération à nous je pense à la
génération de nos enfants dans dix ans
dans 20 ans
quand ils regarderont avec un peu de
recul une campagne électorale comme
celle de 1981 est ce que vous ne pensez
pas qu'ils se demanderont avec
effarement pourquoi nous parlions
tellement de questions comme la durée du
septennat
alors que était en train de mourir de
faim tant d'hommes de femmes d'enfants
et qu'on enfouit c'est dans le sol tant
de bombes
[Musique]